Think about an object, just any object.
What part of it takes up
the most space in memory?
The inside.
It's all the properties it
carries that consume memory.
Is there a way to reduce the amount
of memory an object requires?
Yes, by emptying it.
Core data objects can
actually be emptied
as their properties aren't saved inside
the object, but in a database file.
And that's exactly what core data does.
Every core data object starts empty.
That's called a fault.
Whenever the user asks for the contents
of a certain property, that's when core
data fetch the value from the database,
and it becomes a regular object.
It's just like those old sea monkey ads.
Just add water.
Later on, if that value goes unused for
a certain time, the object becomes
emptied again and becomes a fault.
This is how core data helps keep your
memory footprint as low as possible and
without any intervention on your part.
This is absolutely vital in
an environment with limited memory,
such as an iOS device.